last January we took a look at games
that went mi a revealed and braided
around only to go suddenly quiet and
we're doing it again this year
fortunately for us many of last year's
games returned to the light of day we've
seen more of the next Mirror's Edge
crackdown years of four and scalebound
cliffy bees new project the Shin Megami
Tensei Fire Emblem crossover and even
Kingdom Hearts three other games like
silent Hills have gone the way of the
dodo even so there's still plenty left
in limbo here's what we're thinking
about now now that we've got the Witcher
3
everyone's eager to hear more about CD
Projekt Reds next game cyberpunk 2077
announced back in 2012 cyberpunk is a
mature toned RPG set in a dystopian
future based on designer Mike pon
Smith's cyberpunk tabletop games we
don't know much about the game other
than that and developers have been
unwilling to talk about it
citing a focus on The Witcher 3s
expansions as the reason when we last
spoke to them they said that until the
dust settles which we assume means when
they're completely done with The Witcher
we'll talk about cyberpunk 2077
and with another year of expansions
planned for Geralt adventures we're
betting things will be silent until 2017
we're not really sure what's going on
with MMO RPG of requests necks after its
developers Sony Online Entertainment was
sold off by its parent company now known
as daybreak game company and no longer
under the direction of longtime SOE CEO
John Smedley the studio has been
generally mum about a potential release
last year daybreak announced that they'd
be focusing less on next creation focus
companion game called EverQuest next
landmark and instead pour all their
resources into next itself
unfortunately when GameSpot asked the
team had no updates for us at this time
here's another game we've known about
for years and haven't seen hide nor hair
of Tekken cross Street Fighter the
opposite of 2012 Street Fighter cross
Tekken this new game would focus on the
3d fighting style of the Tekken series
it was announced at San Diego comic-con
back in 2010 there was a character pole
on the Tekken Facebook page in 2012 and
that's it at comic-con again in 2014
producer Katsuhiro Harada told fans to
please relax
Tekken cross street fighter was
definitely still in development but we
still haven't seen the game in action
and Bandai Namco told us that for now
the Tekken team is fully occupied with
bringing Tekken 7 to consoles so maybe
we'll see about this collaboration later
on a little indie game called rime got
some major stage time during Sony's 2013
Gamescom press conference
inspired by ICO Studio Ghibli films and
Salvador Dali paintings Brian is about a
boy trying to escape an island and some
kind of curse the last we saw the game
in action was at Gamescom again in 2014
and we still really don't know much
about it last January to kill works told
us that they were on track for a 2015
release for I'm but the year has passed
when we talked with tequila works again
recently they could only say that rime
is still in development and the
beginning new details
soonish
probably one of the biggest
disappointments of 2015 was an infinite
delay of the phantom dust reboots the
project was announced as a reimagined
version of the beloved classic with all
new gameplay and graphics at e3 2014 in
February 2015 developer darkside games
closed its doors for Microsoft old
funding for phantom dust but Microsoft
swears the game is still in development
just not the version darkside was
working on a representative for
Microsoft told us that they were
quote-unquote still evaluating the right
approach for the reboot
den island 2 was introduced at e3 2014
with a spring 2015 release date in the
works with the ager development while
tech lin was busy with shining light
Dead Island 2 would take place in
California to feature four playable
characters in an 8 player co-op it was
delayed out of spring and in July 2015
it was announced that publisher Deep
Silver had parted ways with Jaeger yeah
you're saying that the break was due to
creative differences Dead Island 2 went
to a still unnamed developer and Deep
Silver could only confirm to GameSpot
that it is still in development you
would be forgiven for forgetting all
about Bethesda's battlecry developed by
an internal studio set up specifically
to support the title battlecry is
described as a multiplayer team-based
online competitive game so basically
it's a MOBA battle kai was revealed at
e3 judges week in 2014 and seen very
little after that with beta signups
going live during e3 2015 in the games
shown briefly during Bethesda's press
conference but in October 5th as de
released a statement expressing concerns
over battle cries quality hence the lack
of updates the company said we are
evaluating what improvements the game
needs to meet our quality standards
a representative for Bethesda told us
recently that this is still the case
and while battle cry is being evaluated
the studio remains busy on multiple
projects you would also be forgiven for
knowing absolutely nothing about hack
and slash action title let it die
remember back in April 2013 when Gao Qi
sudha or suda51 as we know him revealed
the Lille Bergamo project
let it die seems to be the new iteration
of this game an extreme action game a
suitor describes it with a focus on
death when you die in your game your
avatar will appear as an enemy in others
games kind of cool right you'd think but
we haven't seen the game in action yet
the Libra gamma was reintroduced as let
it die during Sony's e3 2014 press
conference and the game is slated to
launch sometime this year I talked to
publish a gung-ho online entertainment
and they got back to me with words from
sudha himself he's
motorboats don't worry it's coming soon
this one's really disappointing Capcom's
dungeon-crawler deep down is a special
case on this list because while we've
seen a trickle of information about this
game from Japanese sources we haven't
heard anything on an international
release which is odd considering the
game was announced as a PlayStation 4
exclusive during a 2013 event debuting
the ps4 hardware in New York City United
States machinery Ono is heading the
project which will launch as
free-to-play and borrows boss fighting
elements similar to From Software's Soul
series we haven't seen the game at any
major trade shows recently and when
contacted Capcom told us that they still
haven't confirmed an international
release for deep-down lover
[Music]
another intriguing indie felon off the
radar is the still untitled project from
Hayes light a new studio Helms by
brothers a tale of two sons director and
writer Joseph Ferris the studio is
operating under EA's publishing label
and all we've seen of the game as a
teaser of two men in a dark boxcar shown
at the 2014 Game Awards recently I sat
down with Ferris and he said that while
the game is coming along nicely he knows
for sure it will not be released until
2017 it's still early in the year so
hopefully we'll still hear about games
like deep down and rime soon after all
we're in one of the only industries
where in terms of marketing potency
silence is not golden at all
[Music]
you